[Music]  everybody's talking these days about how  China China seems to have a leg up on  the United States yeah do you notice  that yeah we have a lot of debt to them  yes yes and and and and the question is  why is China so dominant well we try to  provide some answers to that question  in a segment we call why China is  kicking our ass reason number 929  [Music]  [Music]  why China is pink  [Music]  you said you saw that episode yes  and that no producer handed her a  Kleenex or anything now they just let  her sit there and squirm yeah and I just  was like whoever give the little girl a  Kleenex right I just I felt more mad  about the people making that show right  I bet you in China should get a Kleenex  man I've never seen a more authoritative  turn to camera yeah you're right at that  practising yeah careers and as a news  anchor yeah yeah I'm the [ __ ] news  [Laughter]  [Applause]  that's incredible